ccr5 is a very interesting story and it
is the first project on which I worked
in HIV after a joint Pfizer HIV is the
virus that causes AIDS and it had been
known for a number of years that in
order for HIV to infect the white blood
cells which ultimately kills it needs to
recognize a protein on the surface very
much the same way that a key fits into a
lock and that protein was called cd4 and
everybody knew that there was a need for
a second protein to be used as a landing
pad in a way for the virus to attach
itself and the identified protein was
discovered in 1996 and it was a really
exciting year a number of labs within
the space of weeks identified the
molecular function they identify the
protein called ccr5 they worked out how
the virus uses it and also what made it
particularly exciting was some
epidemiology work which was published
literally weeks after the protein was
identified in that same year and that
showed that a number of humans have a
genetic variation on that receptor which
effectively wipes it from the surface of
the white blood cells and by doing that
that potations render them resistant to
HIV infection so those subjects did not
seem to be infectable by HIV and and
over a decade since its discovery
there's only a handful of what we call
ccr5 Delta thirty two homozygotes who
have been found to be infected by the
virus this was obviously really exciting
because not only validates the target as
a one that if you block you could stop
the virus from entering the cells but
also told us that it would be relatively
safe to do so with a small molecule drug
therefore giving us both both confidence
that it will work and that it will be
safe all in one experiment what ensued
is actually even more interesting
because you would have
so that with this great idea it would be
relatively straightforward to discover
drugs and and I have to say that over a
decade they can since its discovery we
have the only company that has managed
to develop a drug and take you to the
market in skald since entry it was
discovered only a few years after the
discovery of the receptor but it has
taken over a decade to take to get
through over a glittery approvals and to
patients an extremely rewarding
experience to be seeing the project from
start from idea to finish but also a
very enriching one the initial idea was
obviously published and shared by a
number of inventors and perfect I demic
and from assu t'kul companies who worked
on it and almost every farmer who had an
interesting anti-hiv drugs invested in a
CCF ID program and after this first good
idea they had had to be a number of
other good decisions made for that
program to result to a drug and and this
is where my job is really interesting
because the day-to-day discovery process
making the right decision every time is
what gives us the the edge and the
competitive edge over other other
farmers and other labs it was extremely
rewarding to be seeing how our programs
progressed when perhaps others were
finding funding more difficult to
balance the right properties in the same
molecule getting the molecule that works
against this ef5 was easy it was a
matter of a couple of years we had some
pretty potent small molecules that would
block the virus from entering the cell
but then it took another two years to
get them to be safe to get them to be
stable such that they could be given
only once or twice a day and to develop
them into a form that would turn them
into a drug this is really where farmer
has its main strength bring to
all the disciplines the knowledge the
skills that are required for a
scientific discovery to be turned into a
life-saving treatment I will always
remember the first data that came back
from the patient clinical trials where
patients who had run out of options had
gone through two three or more lines of
treatment and failed that had virus that
was resistant to almost everything that
was out there and were put on a regimen
that contained maraviroc and over half
of them responded to that treatment and
and became and suppress the virus to
such an extent that he became
undetectable I'm ever opening that email
one late evening and and having a not my
throat looking at the looking at the
viral load data showing that the
compound that that we've been working on
for over a decade actually worked and
say we're saving lives
obviously feel passionate about
infectious diseases and they're all very
deadly they take a huge toll and I
believe that most of them are treatable
as as we have shown with the progress
that we've made against those that we
chose to focus on we already covered the
neglected diseases such as tuberculosis
malaria another proceeding diseases
which are being increasingly addressed
through public-private partnerships and
the product development partnerships
that we work with i would say that there
is one looming disaster which
unfortunately were not necessarily very
well prepared for and that's influenza
very simple demek of h1n1 swine flu has
shown that once once it has emerged a
new strain of influenza it can be very
difficult to contain h1n1 spread across
the globe in the matter of weeks and
will continue to spread we're perhaps
fortunate that this particular strain is
not very virulent and the drugs are the
two drugs that we developed in the last
decade seem to work against most cases
but there are the signs of resistance at
least one of those two drugs and
resistance will emerge I think it's
important that farmer and academia and
governments work together to recreate a
pipeline of drugs which which would work
in those cases where the two treatments
that we now have would fail or rather
when the two tumors that we have will
fail I feel that the time to invest in
those is now because as we discussed
through the work on ccr5 it takes over a
decade to go from an idea to a drug and
a decade is fast so we need to act now
if we want to be ready for the next for
the next pandemic
public-private partnerships have been
essential in our battle against aids to
start with it's a great example where a
lot of academic research funded by
governments and non-governmental
organizations has produced the number of
targets approaches which then the farmer
has taken on and turned into drugs this
has been pretty successful I think if
you see at the impact that if you look
at the impact that we have had on the
disease but there are still a number of
infectious diseases we're searching but
has not yet taken place I am thinking in
particular of a number of parasitic
diseases or tuberculosis which which are
major health problems in Africa and
increasingly in our own countries and
where perhaps by by lack of funding or
focus on those areas there has been very
little both academic and farmer
investments in developing new treatments
that is changing very rapidly and I
think the landscape over the last four
to five years has transformed
dramatically the pipeline against some
of those diseases is better than it has
ever been to my knowledge there is a
large number of combinations against
malaria new approaches against
tuberculosis which they hadn't been for
a long time and also investments in
diseases diseases but i would call
neglected so human African
trypanosomiasis tigers and visual is
manassas this is a result of of a
concerted effort between the public this
is a result of a concerted effort
between governmental organizations
nongovernmental organizations such as
the Gates Foundation and they Wellcome
Trust and farmer and increasingly we see
those partnerships between academia
public funding bodies and farmer in
order to accelerate discovery and
development of such drugs I think for
diseases like tuberculosis malaria where
the returning investment is perhaps less
obvious than in other
disease areas these partnerships are
essential for success
we recently announced that collaboration
with meds for malaria medicine for
malaria venture is a product development
partnership as we now call them the
mission is to enable and accelerate
discovery and development of new
treatments for malaria and our joint
efforts I'm confident with resulting
that the way we will work with them is
we will make available our chemical file
these are all the compounds that we have
synthesized and optimized over the
course of decades it's like crown jewels
it's where we would go if we started our
own drug discovery program we will make
them available to the mmv and in return
we will be accessing their expertise and
that of their network of collaborators
in fighting the disease the objective is
to identify starting points small
molecules which will be able to kill the
parasite that causes malaria and from
there to develop those into new
treatments I'm very confident that with
a joint efforts we will be successful
and in the months to come I'm sure there
will be many more good news to share
you